climate Zar John KY blowing wind during
a climate lecture in Dubai but did the
greenhouse gases that he wanted to
eliminate come from
within I find myself getting more and
more militant because I do not
understand how adults who are in
position of responsibility can be
avoiding responsibility for taking away
those things that are killing people on
a daily basis and and the reality is
that um yep
H but let's pass on the sophomoric humor
for a second and get to the bigger
picture Carrie letting one rip on
Banning coal
plants now we don't need that
necessarily to tell us we ought to be
transitioning out of coal there
shouldn't be any more Coal Fired power
plants permitted anywhere in the world
that's how you can do something for
health and the reality is that we're not
doing it
Lurch also trying to clear the air on
whether politics plays a role in his
climate Crusade I'm Guided by the
science uh and I can tell you honestly
there is zero politics or ideology in
any decision that the President Biden
has made or the Administration has made
we are driven by the
science something seriously stinks about
Biden's green agenda they want to ban
gas cars Force everyone to drive an EV
but get this it's been 2 years since
Congress gave Biden $7.5 billion to
build thousands of evv chargers across
the country but holy cylindra that
program has yet to install a single
charger
well we've had breaking news now we have
Breaking Wind news uh dealt it yeah
exactly once again uh we tackled the
news no one else will cover this would
this story would not have happened on
the five were it not for me being
employed by Fox News this this is true
this is this is your dream come true
segment exactly after 13 years you
finally have the you the producers
really understand you and I think that's
a really great step in your relationship
but isn't this kind of it's it's an
analogy or a microcosm of how these
climate hysterics are often the biggest
offenders when producing carbon
emissions right this one just came out
of his butt but let's face it he's got
he's got tons of boats tons of houses
tons of uh private jets flying around
and he joins Bill Gates who today wrote
In The New York Times that very wealthy
individuals should also be making
changes to their Lifestyles to bring
their emissions close to zero he says
that if you fly in a private jet as I do
you can afford the extra cost of
sustainable Aviation flu fuel made from
lowc carbon crops and waste I I would
love to see a rich person who raises
their hand and says yes please
get let me experiment in my plane with
crops and waste well I mean it's
interesting he says waste judge is he
alluding to the fact that one day maybe
John krey could power his own jet with
his flatulence yeah well you know when
you think about it it was a few years
ago when they said they didn't want us
to eat meat anymore because of the
flatulence of cows I mean they wanted to
get rid of all the cows I mean I'm
waiting for when they say if you're too
old and you pass flatulence we're going
to get rid of you too they're doing that
in Canada they are
I don't know who knows anyway but the
whole point is in a year and a half the
Carrie family has emitted 325 tons of
carbon from their private jet I mean and
you know KLA Harris over Thanksgiving
was wishing a Happy Thanksgiving from
her family to ours and she's standing
right in front of a gas stove I mean the
hypocrisy is incredible but I think the
one quote that really got me was when
Terry says that we're not going to
tolerate we're going to phase out coold
fired power plants all over over the
world except wait a minute you're you're
you're giving China the ability to make
lithium batteries and they're developing
two Coal fire power plants a week now I
think they're in the world the last I
checked but the truth is all of this
money 7 and a half billion dollars we've
got we've built so far zero we've
installed zero and yet they expect us to
by the end of the decade to be able to
have 50% of us in these EVS when
everybody's got anxiety about getting
into one mhm no Chargers around there
you know Jessica Let's uh let's talk
about the real story here it's not that
Carri broke wind it's that more this
doesn't happen more often don't you
think I mean we act like it's a but
isn't this just something we do all the
time but we just don't talk about it so
for the first time ever if he had said
Jessica you were saying before the show
started cuz I was saying that I'm
actually surprised that there aren't
more far s caught on live television
with the amount of gas that humans are
passing constantly more boys than girls
by the way are doing it sex you go fine
you go girl on that one and I Jesse's
not factchecking that's an interesting
point if you transition from male to
female would you break wind less I don't
know how the sphincter changes in the in
the evolution I just actually a producer
just said the time I thought he was
saying please stop this right now um
it was exciting though and I was curious
about if you had like a fart clause in
your contract like you get to talk about
it a certain amount of times without
hearing from man well the onus is on
Fox oh that's good um just a little bit
there should be more EV Chargers if you
have the money for it definitely do it
but on the emissions from the Cary
family it's the hin family right he
married Teresa Hines of ketchup Fame
they are the ones with the money and the
private jets he flies commercial for all
government business as everybody has
before these goals are aspirational and
that's what these conferences are for we
talk about this with Davos right and
everyone shows up and they say all these
incredible things that they're going to
do to make us a more balanced equal
society and it doesn't happen and then
everyone gets back and they're gas
guzzlers and all of it and rides off
into the distance yeah and you you may
rais a good point uh John cary's money
comes from the Hines family what is
Hines it's ketchup what you with ketchup
you put it on beef what does beef do
causes you to fart I don't think the
circle of life is complete good steak
doesn't need katchup though yeah that is
true Jesse uh I I come to you last
because I feel like you're going to
pierce through
this fog of Greg I'm glad you brought up
Hines yes because they own craft and
that kills people Cole isn't killing
that many people I think all the food
it's the mac and cheese it's the cheese
product his family is poisoning oh the
people of this country with
preservatives and additives and sugar
and that's what's actually killing us a
few coal plants come on also Greg you
can't trust a man with fillers at that
age Botox at that age that brings up the
question of judgment what kind of
judgment does that show what kind of
arrogance or egotism is that a word
egotism it it is now do that show yes so
he's going around sticking stuff in his
face wagging his finger and telling the
whole world what to do no one cares now
I know why they don't like us in this
country it's because of people like Don
krey it's not Trump it's Carrie they're
sick of them and 15% of the US economies
run on coal we're just going to shut
down 15% of the economy because Carrie
wants to that's stupid why do we even
listen to John krey he's an idiot he's a
maniac he's going around telling people
to shut their economies down that's
insane this guy is
disqualified and Joe Biden after three
years hasn't built a single charging
station yep not One charging but they
say Greg that this is so urgent that the
world's going to end we have to do this
well then why don't they warp speed it
yeah why don't they cut all the red tape
and get these charger stations like they
did with the vaccine they don't care
it's not that urgent they're not capable
right they have been built but just with
private dollars yeah but not our
tax half billion dollar there's a
distinction between private funds and
why can't Biden build one charger why
can't we do as
well where's the charger okay I think uh
I think this is why they want us to eat
insects because if you fart all you're
going to hear is crickets okay okay this
is done I can't wait for your show
tonight yeah it's going to be all it's
going to be 60 Minutes of fart jokes hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now